since
you were the president of nra last month
january to january gun sales is up 80
2 million plus sales of firearms last
month is the third biggest month
ever last year in 2020 i think we're up
64
from the year prior to that the numbers
are just staggering what's going on
right now
why why are so many americans buying 80
more guns in january compared to last
january
why now what what what are they thinking
about i'm curious what you'll say about
that well
you know first of all you had a
president last january
named donald trump who is a big
supporter of the second amendment
okay number two you now have a president
who's not a big supporter
of the second amendment and people are
very concerned about being able to
protect their families
look we've saw we saw uh the summer of
riot
right with organizations that are now
quote
i don't know how they're going to do
this but these are organizations blm
intifada boogaloo uh
q anon who were rioting all over major
cities portland seattle
milwaukee l.a washington d.c
burning destroying and people looked at
it and said hmm
i don't have a way of protecting my
family and they went out and bought
firearms
okay and they can still do that today
except things are about to get a whole
lot worse here in the state of virginia
because we got a crazy governor who is
literally forgive me for putting it this
way but this is the truth
he is a a baby killing
gun grabbing race baiter who is going to
come after the guns
okay let me just a quick story without
confessing to any crimes
i've already been there once never again
when our kids when our grandkids we had
11 grandsons and seven granddaughters
when when they turned 14 i'm allowed to
give a
president pre a present to their
birthday and it's a box and it's a long
box
and inside the on the front of the box
it says
if you learn to use everything in this
box you'll never go hungry you'll never
be lost and you need fear nothing
and i will show you how and they open
the box up and the first thing they see
isn't a firearm they know there's one in
the box because they can feel the weight
of it
and they've seen it happen with their
older siblings cousins
and the first thing they pick up is the
holy bible i said it just happens that
half the months a year have 31 proverbs
in it
right and you know there's 31 proverbs
and i want you to go and the very first
thing about using this present
is i want you to do one a day and come
back and give me a book report 31 days
from now
right and they do and the second thing
is a map and a compass
and i i i used to teach land navigation
to marines right
and and they there's there's just like
you got in a marine
you know training command you've got
engineer stakes and a metal box welded
to it
out in the woods at terrain features and
i show them how to use that map sheet
125 000 scale and that compass how to
navigate
and of course the third thing is and
after i teach them that i said
then i'm going to let you have this
shotgun it's going to be engraved on the
side that this is a gift from granddad
not my name
just granddad okay and it's your name on
it and it's your birthday
and i will take you out and i will show
you how to take it apart and put it back
together blindfolded
then i'll show you how to clean it and
then i'll show you how to shoot it
so that at the end of the day you're not
going to waste it as a shotgun
you're not going to waste it missing
birds and i can i have a wonderful
experience doing that kind of thing
there's lots of people who are going to
find that to be unlawful because
a 14 year old is now supposed to get a
background check
what the hell is a background check on a
14 year old kid look like
and the only wrinkle in that fabric was
after one of the girls watched her older
brother get
a shotgun she asked granddad where's
mine
so i got to go out and buy another
shotgun that's that's it if i give that
shotgun tour am i breaking the law in
virginia i don't know yet
that's why people are pressed now to get
a firearm that's why concealed carry
permits are out
just off the charts and and and that's a
good reason
that americans are still able to protect
their families against the uncertainty
of somebody showing up on your back
porch trying to knock your door down
and they're not the law they're
criminals and so
given that given the temperature of the
times i think it's appropriate
what's unfortunate is the fact that
virginia is a big military state like
what do you what are you doing touching
virginia you know well
the history the rich history of virginia
like i understand some other states
but virginia's decked out with the
military so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]